[Música]
para ser reina de una escuela de samba
hace falta un torrente de energía y una
gran coordinación con los percusionistas
mayara es considerada una de las mejores
bailarinas de la nueva generación de
sambistas
Yo casi siempre estoy escuchando
nuestros percusionistas porque mi cuerpo
es eso mi cuerpo es música y danza yo
coloco todos los instrumentos de la
batería en mi cuerpo
cada escuela de samba está dividida en
alas no pueden faltar los fascistas que
bailan la Samba
un ala de bayanas las mujeres mayores
que representan la tradición de la samba
Y por supuesto el abanderado y su
doncella que levantan el estandarte de
la escuela
delante de los jurados la bandera no
puede quedar enrollada ni caer ni
golpearse contra el suelo Tampoco puede
caer ningún elemento de nuestra ropa
mientras estamos danzando
el desfile en el sambodromo es una ópera
itinerante donde cada detalle importa
todos los años cada escuela tiene que
producir un espectáculo diferente y
presentar una trama original
desarrollada a través de la canción de
los disfraces y de la danza
el entusiasmo es un requisito
indispensable
La mejor parte ocurre antes aquí antes
del carnaval el espectáculo en el
sambódromo es para que el mundo lo vea
el espectáculo del pueblo El que
emociona De verdad está aquí el alma de
la escuela el alma del zambista están
aquí en el ensayo
y el público participa vibrando a cada
nota la Samba consigue reunir a
generaciones y personas desconocidas a
través de un sentimiento inexplicable
una pasión tan Arrolladora que permite
vencer Incluso el calor tórrido del
verano carioca
[Música]